we've already talked about the absurdity
of Trump's new a muslim-majority country
travel ban it's illegal it's immoral
it's ineffective it was implemented
horribly and it actually makes us less
safe I don't want to rehash that what I
want to get to is that there's a growing
talking point on the low information
right that's gotten big enough that I
need to address it now especially so
that our logic and reason contingent in
the audience is prepared to debunk and
push back against it the talking point
is as follows hey what Trump is doing is
no big deal because former President
Barack Obama also banned refugees and
was worried about the same list of
countries as what Trump is doing now and
it's basically the exact same thing so
why are you criticizing Trump for
something Obama did here is an example
of this assertion from Donald Trump's
Facebook page note the highlighted
yellow part where Trump said on January
29th my policy is similar to what
President Obama did in 2011 when he
banned visas for refugees from Iraq for
six months the seven countries named in
the executive order are the same
countries previously identified by the
Obama administration as sources of
terror if you want an example of
alternative facts this is at the top of
the list intentionally and completely
misleading but the trumpets are loving
it they won't stop emailing me and
tweeting me and commenting on YouTube
about how this is the same thing Obama
did this is an example of what about ISM
what about ISM is a Russian of all
sources propaganda technique when you
respond to any criticism with what about
X when X is something else before I tell
you why this is nothing like what
President Obama did think for a second
if it were true that Obama did the same
thing as Trump wouldn't you have heard
at least some right-wingers the more
reasonable ones praising Obama for doing
this during his presidency the reason
they didn't because President Obama did
nothing like this what the Obama
administration did is review the way
that we vet refugees from Iraq only
refugees and only from one country Obama
was not prioritizing Christians and
prioritizing Muslims as a president
Trump said that he plans to do
Trump's executive order pertains to all
types of non diplomatic travelers this
includes tourists and business travelers
this is something that is completely
unlike what President Obama did the
Obama administration did not prevent
anyone from those seven countries from
entering the US on principle
Trump's order has they listed those
countries on a list for actually being
banned from entry what President Obama's
list was and it's true that there's an
overlap on the list the President Obama
lists served the purpose of reviewing
the vetting procedures reviewing the
vetting procedures the Obama
administration didn't even ban refugees
from Iraq the way that Trump's defenders
are saying that they did there was not a
single month during the entire Obama
administration during which Iraqi
refugees didn't come to the United
States this was a review of refugee
protocol related to specific threats
including an arrest of two Iraqi
refugees in Kentucky but again it is
nothing like what President Trump is
doing it just has nothing to do with it
and it's kind of funny to see Trump
groveling in this way because if you
compare Obama's and Trump's approval
numbers there night and day Obama's way
more popular so I really hope he doesn't
continue using this childish excuse
because there's so many things that
Obama did that were right-wing deporting
so many people the drone strikes so I
hope this connection stops here Trump's
administration once again is trying to
solve a problem that doesn't exist the
Obama administration's changes to the
vetting are still in effect they already
have made the vetting process much more
strict we have the longest vetting
process in the world for Refugees 18 to
24 months Trump is trying to say that
his order was not drastic or novel by
equating it to what President Obama did
which is also sort of unusual I thought
everything Obama did was bad shouldn't
Trump just say that Obama was weak on
vetting and that what he's doing is
different and better all of a sudden
saying that what he's doing is the same
as what Obama did
is a really weird way to defend his
actions and even so it's kind of just a
childish excuse I can get away with it
because he got away with it I mean
that's not how it works in the real
world no it should be defended by Trump
on its own merits yeah it shouldn't even
matter
not only did Obama not do the same thing
and I shouldn't matter whether Obama did
the same thing Trump should be able to
defend it on its own merits if you've
heard of yellow journalism we're in a
new era now where we're in a world of
orange alternative facts orange is the
new facts is is the way I'm saying it
that I don't know if that one resonates
with you at all